did you think that Knight Cutler was
gonna be about Jake Gyllenhaal playing
Kurt Wagner the awesome transporting
blue mutant from x-men yeah we did too
here's some other movies that comic book
fans were really hoping with the
adaptations of their favorite characters
only to be slightly disappointed
gambit starring Colin Firth car throwing
mutant gambit is one of the most popular
x-men a movie all about gambit would
have been so cool but this movie was
about a con artist and an art gallery
The Iceman starring Michael Shannon this
wasn't about Bobby Drake the x-men
mutant it was a crime thriller about a
hitman boy were we left in the cold
waiting for Superman we were really
hoping for this one to be about the Man
of Steel but it was a documentary on
America's education system rogue this
wasn't about rogue the mutant from x-men
it was about crocodiles The Sentinel
starring Michael Douglas I saw this
movie and kept waiting for a giant
mutant hunting robot to show up nope not
even close
venom everyone loves the Spider Man
antihero venom and a standalone movie
would be so cool we were all pretty sad
Archangel Daniel Craig as Archangel how
cool does that sound oh wait it has
nothing to do with x-men at all Phoenix
Phoenix a movie about Jean Grey nope
Ray Liotta plays a cop with a gambling
addiction kingpin Wilson Fisk is one of
spider-man and Daredevils best villains
this 90s movie had nothing to do with
Fisk at all it was about Bill Murray and
Bolin and last but not least the 80s
classic Flashdance who was anyone else
hoping Flashdance would be about the
flash dancing no okay what movies did
you think we're going to be about a
superhero lets superhero movies do you
like the most
let us know in the comments below